up now Jack Jack Houston we're getting  to the bottom of some Hollywood hearsay  that's got us shaken and stirred there's  a lot of buzz and rumors swirling that  you could in fact be the next James Bond  that's exactly the purely rumors I've  not heard I haven't had a single  conversation about this should have  stayed away you should have killed me  okay so he may not be bond yet but  Jack's got another iconic film role  locked in the reimagining of the 1959  classic Ben Hur which is out today and  the father of 2 has some famous friends  in his corner namely dad to beat Adam  Levine your daughter  IATI Prince Lee just minted her as their  new baby's BFF on Instagram the Audion  might oh my god for them old best  friends so yeah I hope they are that's  so sweet